hey y'all Oh weird all right hello
everybody no hey oh I'm Vaughn
I am a tasty show producer and I'm gonna
show you why I love making mesmerizing
dessert videos strawberry cheesecake
macarons was really like my first big
video here at tasty I was a French and
film double major so this is really like
literally the perfect job for me I've
always taken a really strong liking to
desserts in general I worked at a bakery
after I graduated from college
I've always loved Lucky's emphases and
so I applied for this job at tasty and
was so nervous because I was like this
is the perfect job for me I have to get
it and when you apply for a job at tasty
they ask you to make a top-down food
video and I think that I should make a
matcha ginger citrus macaron which is
like the craziest flavor combination
that no one on tasty or none of our
tasty audience would really like or get
unless they were like taste Japan or
something I saved all of my macarons and
I actually brought them into my
in-person interview they were like this
kid is the biggest suck-up of all time
like who is he and then they tasted my
macarons they were like actually these
are pretty good we should give him a
second chance
and thankfully they did give me a second
chance and I knew when I started here
that I had to make a macaron video so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna try to
find a flavor combination that the
Tastee audience is gonna like strawberry
cheesecake so on top of this crazy
flavor combination I really want to make
them look swirl like a strawberry
cheesecake so what I did was I combined
the two colors of better and I piped
both of those into a bigger piping bag
and then I swirled them around and
people were watching me in the taste
studio like what the hell is this kid
doing I didn't have them taste
yet because I wanted to like save them
all for the end and then they tasted the
macarons I passed them out and that was
really like my first time where I felt
validated almost in the tasty studio it
was a really gratifying feeling and then
when the video came out like a week
later I remember being on a plane from
DC and I saw that the video went up I
was like okay I gotta turn my phone off
I'm on a plane flew back landed in New
York City and it had like 10 million
views when I heard that I was like yes
this is awesome this is like the HAI
that you get when you make a viral video
was really like my first time where I
felt like this is where I meant to be I
know that this is gonna be a place that
I'm at for a long time and we ate
macarons for like four weeks after that
because I made like 150 of them when I
started as a tasty producer we had to
make to one pot recipes and then our
third video had to be like a mashup I
really wanted to make a dessert because
I love sweets and a huge sweet tooth it
was wintertime so I was feeling
something swore Z s'mores a word I was
like I want to make something
s'mores flavored and I wanted to be good
for a party so I came up with his wacky
idea of s'mores cheesecake pops when I
first tested this recipe out I made my
no-bake cheesecake base and then I
rolled a whole bunch of marshmallows and
when you're making a tasty video
you're not exactly able to cook your
recipe all the way through without
stopping because you have to like change
your camera's change your lenses get
different angles from the side so I go
and I get the marshmallows out of the
oven
and then I'm like oh wait I have to do
my graham cracker base so I make my
graham cracker base and then I go to put
my marshmallows into the batter and
they're like brick salad I ended up
having to do more marshmallows and then
because the marshmallows were so hot it
made my batter soupy and I was like what
the hell is going on so I learned from
my mistakes and I left the broiled
marshmallows cool for three to four
minutes I just had to get like really
fun with those chocolate dipping shots
because there's absolutely nothing
sexier than beautiful shots of melted
chocolate it ended up tasting like
toasted marshmallow cheesecake which was
awesome tasty 101 is really really near
and dear to my heart
my boss was essentially like we don't
have anybody doing just YouTube videos
we've tried out a couple of things on
YouTube but you really want a dedicated
team of producers to just play around
with different long-form recipe videos
long-form content in general for a
YouTube audience and we were thinking
about shows it was a no-brainer
tasty 101 had to be one of our shows
everybody knew it people loved Claire's
voice we had a new person in LA Alexis
who was also really gifted with recipes
and had a great voice as well people
really loved Claire's voice it's really
just another flavor enhancer so when we
were thinking about a first season of
tasty one a wonder if he really brought
what do people really need to know about
I quickly learned that making long-form
content especially tasty 101 is a whole
different ballgame than just like your
normal recipe video they require a lot
of planning a lot of recipe development
because what we're putting out there is
what we think the tasties perfect recipe
for something is so Claire and I took a
couple days to come up with like the
perfect recipe for a pound cake we made
all these like tarts and muffins and we
had some like class some that we made
and things like that and we just like
had
smorgasbord of desserts out on this
table in making that video I just
remember like having so much fun with
playing around with those beauty shots
getting those kind of cool cushions and
flyover shots and like really showcasing
how sexy desserts can be we're able to
really highlight the most amazing
aspects of one thing and make it look
incredible
so when we're thinking about season two
I was like look one of my passions in
life is decorating cake and I love
decorating cake I personally will spend
like hours on my phone at night when I'm
trying to go to sleep watching cake
decorating videos on Instagram it's like
an actual problem but I really want to
do a five beautiful ways to decorate
cakes ideo because it's something that
people love watching we need to
capitalize on this so Claire and I came
into the taste of studio one morning and
what started off is like a cake
decorating video with just a few tips
and tricks quickly turned into like a
we're gonna make five unreal cakes
Claire and I'm like we're pulling our
hair out and about to pull each other's
hair out for this video but by the end
when we were going through and doing
like the voiceover and everything we
were like wow this was so much fun and
this is something that we're pretty good
at so we're gonna continue to do this
which is why when season three came
about we were like alright gotta do
desserts again
let's do brownies I worked with one of
our recipe developers sue and we just
made like eight batches of brownies one
day and it was the best day of my whole
entire life because we were just eating
brownies all day long that's really the
best part about being a tasty producer
is that you
all day long when we do a tasty 101
video it's always kind of like what is
that one crazy technique that people are
gonna go and watch this video and be
like whoa that is a cool thing that I've
never seen before we both remember this
recipe where a baker like takes the pan
of brownies and just whacks it against
the table halfway through baking turns
the sheet of brownies around and puts it
back in the oven so it gets like that
nice crackly top keeps them really
really moist but not dense like these
are literally the best brownies I've
ever had in my whole entire life and I
can firmly say that the people of
BuzzFeed New York who got to try these
brownies said the exact same thing in
tasty 101 - what I love is that I was
able to use a lot nicer cameras and I
was able to showcase what I could do in
terms of like slow motion filming and
flyover shots and everything like that
which really inspired me and I think
that that's one of the big reasons why
we made made by hand tasty is made by
hand is a very artistic look and insight
into how everyday people make something
by hand exacting that human emotion
exacting that human condition from the
passion that somebody has when they make
thing thousands of times every single
day and then came Asian Pacific American
Heritage Month
yeah a pan I wanted personally to do
this tea house in New York that I had
been to before what really drew me to
that was they had these really
traditional Japanese tea cakes and
pastries but then they also had this
really cool modern take on pastries as
well and I thought that that was perfect
way to showcase the juxtaposition
between the old and the new when I dug a
little deeper and I liked when there to
talk to the people who owned it I found
out that not only was it like a
completely family-run business but it
was also like women doing these
incredible things and I was like this is
perfect
I am so into it when I graduated from
school I moved to Thailand for like
seven months to teach English and my
favorite thing to do after school would
be to play badminton with my students
and then I would go and get like an iced
americano and a little matcha tea cake
from the cafe across the street when I
went to the tea house here in New York
really brought back those memories for
me and that was when I was kind of like
food is a memory every single flavor
every single taste every single
ingredient that you've ever experienced
is and can be tied to a specific moment
in your life and I think that that
emotion was something that was super
touching to me when I went there and I
just got this rush of nostalgia and I
think that that's something that was
really cool with that video was that we
were able to learn that food is more
about just the way something tastes or
the way something looks it's about the
story behind it from there we saw that
people seem to really like the human
element behind all of these stories I've
gotten to meet and talk to these amazing
people that have dedicated their lives
to making one thing it's really special
to see someone with a passion so deep
and so ingrained in themselves that
they're committing their whole entire
lives to perfecting one craft I think
that that's what really resonates with
our audience the most is that like food
is inherently connected to memories when
I get in the kitchen and bake something
I'm automatically brought back to my
childhood getting up on like a rainy
Saturday morning and baking with my mom
and my grandma in the kitchen I've had a
lot of life experiences you know I've
lived in three different countries
I moved up to New York City when I was
23 without a job living in this tiny
cramped apartment and it was negative
ten degrees in January that's like the
time in my life that's connected most to
like instant ramen no I'm sure when I go
out and I film a mesmerising dessert
video I don't just go and say like okay
I'm gonna set the camera here and I'm
just gonna let it roll our food and the
way that we showcase food is done from
that human perspective and we try to
always
how is this gonna make something feel
when we put it down
I always try to think about how is
something gonna play into not just the
overall video but like the psychology of
the video how is that gonna make you as
a viewer feel when you see this 70 year
old woman who's dedicated her life to
making mochi and honestly that's the
coolest part of my job is seeing in the
comments and getting direct messages of
like hey I saw your brownie video I made
your brownie recipe I loved it
I'm gonna put pretzels on top of it and
bring it to my cookie swap this money as
the most gratifying thing is to be able
to see like the fruits of our labor or
in my case the cakes of our labor that
was really dumb
[Music]